what is going on guys and girls it's
ghostrobo and welcome to bioshock the
collection the entire franchise done up
in gorgeous 1080p running up to 60
frames per second all the single player
DLC and coming your way soon September
13th in North America September 16th
internationally for xbox one playstation
4 and pc were here with bioshock two
obviously underwater admiring the
serenity in that suit even the ocean
cannot harm you this is good but rapture
is the death of many great men alone you
will not last long you can still reach
the train station find me there this
time around Tenenbom is our guide
instead of Andrew Ryan and we actually
are a big daddy menacing boss from
bioshock 1 is the role we take here in
bioshock 2 they've added a lot to your
arsenal they've added different styles
of enemies different environments the
big sister who we saw tear the glass
apart
and learn a lot more about rapture the
origins of the Little Sisters the Big
Daddy and what makes this place tick
this big daddy currently protecting his
little sister as best he can a thumper
making sure she gets the atom she needs
and will make sure that we show you why
this game is actually incredibly good I
i played this when it came out and a
huge Bioshock fan love the first game
and really love the second game as well
I think it it tackles some very
interesting themes it has really really
cool characters adds these underwater
segments and I like the addition of
being able to wield both plasmids and
weapons at the same time and the big
sister provides an interesting challenge
I'm much faster and more rambunctious if
you will opponent than the big daddys so
we're going to go through show you some
combat and see how pretty things look
now on current-gen consoles and they
definitely do look good they have redone
this in quite a wonderful way and so
we'll explore the ocean see the sights
maybe a shark
maybe a giant squid I wish you could go
to rapture that would be a
intensification but a wonderful one I'm
currently actually at 2k checking out
the game they were kind enough to fly me
up here to bring you guys this early
look at my favorite franchise I think in
gaming history so to relive these
moments is super cool there's a big
sister again always watching where's she
headed let's say let's get back inside
and show you guys the combat will be
checking out Bioshock 1 and infinite as
well with extended looks going up on my
channel re-enter rapture see what awaits
all right we've skipped forward just a
couple of minutes here to show off some
plasma acquisition in combat you'll
notice we are dual wielding like I
mentioned we got the rivet gun here
we've got the electro bolt on our left
hand we also could use a drill and be a
true Big Daddy brute force beast let's
grab this here and I love the aesthetic
of Bioshock you'll notice here it's got
this very cool 50 60s vibe that's all
its own so these games stood out
aesthetically and artistically back in
the day in their original release so now
having them be all all done up in 1080p
it just adds almost a perfect mixture of
style and substance and I'll get to use
telekinesis here in a quick second she
knows the way story still at the center
and we will make sure that these guys
experience a little bit of that
themselves there we go good night sleep
tight lid on fire oh what a sight will
head down and oh gosh starting off
aggressive this game pulls no punches
take a few down got still a couple more
guys I'm there heal up and let's grab
another one of these boom there we go
again that super cool combo of using the
plasmids plus the guns to work together
to really wipe these splicers out is
what makes Bioshock to really stand
apart from bioshock 1 let's see how
crazy combat can get here apply some
traps prepare for this arena we got
splicers come in every which way and
we're going to make sure they pay I
think there's some things to hack so
we'll do that trying to manage all of
our resources and all of the enemies
simultaneously a their comeback drilling
you that feels so good after facing that
drill in bioshock 1 against the big data
getting to use it now against splicers
is absolutely awesome and telekinesis
can be used here as well good night good
luck goodbye they are having a frickin
party over here in the fire and we trap
rivet and regular rivet them all to
death we hold off the splicers and get
to continue our quest now I must leave
you and I am sorry for this but there
are others I must help before the city
two rounds is Manson Claire he is an
ally and will guide you to Eleanor
goodbye hair Delta and good luck so as
Tenenbaum says goodbye we will as well
Bioshock 2 continues an extended look on
my channel and we'll explore more of
these areas via the train and the entire
collection comes out again September 13
to North America September 16
internationally it feels good to be back
in the world of rapture and hopefully
you guys had fun with us today if you
did let us know what you think until
next time thanks so much for watching
make sure to drink some'a chocolate we
see you all later
you